on continue sur cette suite on va
maintenant parler éducation alors si
vous avez fréquenté les bancs de
l'université à la sortie du lycée
vous avez certainement le souvenir d'une
liberté et certaines ou en tout cas
d'être parfois un peu perdus dans ce
nouveau mode d'organisation basé sur
l'autonomie une note du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur a révélé le
taux de réussite au niveau des licences
dans les universités est la première
université de france et et cocorico pour
50 ans ni mine puisque c'est
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines avec un taux de 56,4 % c'est
notre chiffre du jour
et puis une valeur ajoutée de 13,8
points la valeur ajoutée c'est la
capacité à faire ou non réussir ses
étudiants alors comment lui est ce qu a
décroché cette première place devant
notamment d'autres universités comme
celle d'angers ou de midi pyrénées on va
en parler avec vous daniel arnaud de
bonsoir vous êtes rattaché à la
direction de la réussite et de
l'insertion professionnelle au sein de
l'ue vs qu est donc on va parler avec
vous d'un système qui a été mis en place
et environ trois ans avec ta système
d'accompagnement qui s'appelle abri
c'est assez amusant tour accompagnement
bilan réorganisation et insertion et
orientations et actions
et oui et c'est peut-être ça la clé de
la réussite alors le but de ce système
qui a été mis en place il ya trois ans
c'était vraiment d'éviter le décrochage
absolument c'était les objectifs au
départ quand nous avons répondu à un
appel à projets du fonds
d'expérimentation pour la jeunesse
c'était 2
d'analysé et de recenser les difficultés
des étudiants inscrits en première année
notamment en première année de licence
et de définir avec eux un projet d'étude
un projet professionnel et de les
accompagner pour la réalisation de ce
projet qui les aident bien sûr assuré
parce qu'on l'avait dit à ce qui est
important de s'intéresser aux premières
années parce que je l ai dit en
préambule quand on a été sur les bancs
de la fac en première année c'était c30
parce que c'est un peu la tranquillité
la liberté en tout cas est là donc c'est
important de vraiment les prendre dès la
première année comment voulez les
repérer ces étudiants décrochent alors
effectivement nous les même si
l'université ne ressemble plus à ce
qu'elle était auparavant et beaucoup
d'idées reçues encore assure à ce
niveau-là et l'accompagnement est
vraiment bien plus important que lui ne
l'était auparavant
et justement c'est à la première absence
ou la troisième absence plutôt en
travaux dirigés les enseignants et les
responsables pédagogiques aussi qui nous
qui nous consultent pour pour
accompagner ces étudiants alors ça peut
être aussi le bouche à oreille les
autres directions les collègues qui
dirigent vers nous ces étudiants qui
sont en risque de décrochage avons dit
dès la troisième absent sans entraves
aux dirigeants s'assurer qu'ils sont
signalées dès la 3eme absences sont
travaux dirigés
qu'est ce que c'est sale explique le
décrochement comme ça alors le le
décrochage s'est il peut venir de
plusieurs de plus de plusieurs
situations souvent effectivement il
vient d'une d'un voeu qui a été réalisée
sur admission post bac et qui n'est pas
réalisé donc lisons leur deuxième voeu
ils ne sont pas satisfaits de cela
quelquefois ils s'aperçoivent qu'ils ne
sont pas au niveau dans la formation
dans laquelle ils sont inscrits où ils
ont aussi des difficultés financières ou
sociales
ils peuvent être aussi bien sûr envoyé
chez nous par le biais de l'action
sociale d'accord il n'ya pas coder n'a
pas qu'un qu'une problématique j'allais
dire de pédagogique pédagogique
présidentielle oui elle peut absolument
ils rencontrent beaucoup de difficultés
beaucoup d'étudiants de nos étudiants
sont obligés de travailler et ont du mal
à combiner a effectivement les études et
le travail qu'elle a financièrement vous
pouvez bien servi ce qui était alors
effectivement il ya aussi un service
social et social est là pour pour les
accompagner dans ces difficultés là vous
à nous expliquer le suivi de celle à
savoir une fois on les a repérés ils
sont en bout leur troisième absence ils
sont repérés vous allez nous expliquer
après le travail qui est fait à
l'exceptionnel mais d'abord on va aller
direction les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines et nous sommes allés demander
aux habitants ce qu'il faudrait faire
justement pour que les étudiants
décrochent - à la fac et vous allez
entendre moi je crois qu'ils tombent
assez juste aller on écoute les saint
quentinois faut les mettre en alternance
parce que 20 des jeunes en alternance on
n'a pas le choix sinon ben non il
faudrait faire des td - d'amphi et
rendra la présence obligatoire plus les
encadrer pour qu'il sente obligée d'y
aller parce que sinon s'ils sentent pas
obligés va ils font un peu la fête
partout il faut en tout cas certainement
que le monde professionnel et les ans et
les universités soient capables de se
parler un peu plus parce qu'il ya
clairement un décalage entre les
attentes du monde professionnel est ce
qu'on est capable de fournir en
université ça c'est certain
ce qui compte c'est la méthodologie
puisqu'elle à l'université ils sont en
d'autonomie et même sinon on essaye de
les préparer je sais que c'est ce qui
manque beaucoup
une meilleure orientation à la base à
partir du lycée voilà cibler plus les
étudiants leurs attentes leurs secteurs
on a besoin d'avoir un peu plus d'argent
pour subvenir à plus d'une chose qui
permettra aux étudiants peut-être de
mieux se consacrer à leurs études
arnaud on a entendu un méthodologie
c'était je pense était certainement une
professeur de l'université de calgary
si la méthodologie l'aide financière on
a entendu aussi une jeune femme nous
parler d'orientation
donc comment sont suivis justement ces
élèves dits décrocheurs
alors il en organise pour eux un rendez
vous avec une conseillère en orientation
et en insertion professionnelle et dans
ce premier entretien on fait un
diagnostic en fait des difficultés et on
essaye de devoir est de reprendre en
rendez vous alors ça se passe en
plusieurs rendez-vous ainsi jusqu'à 10
voilà on peut consacrer un certain
nombre d'heures à chaque étudiant mesan
accompagnement qui individualise et bien
sûr donc une fois le diagnostic établi
en la conseillère accompagne pour l'aide
à la définition d'un nouveau projet ou
d'une réorientation et tout ça se fait
sur donc plusieurs rendez vous et au
final c'est tout au long de l'année et
au final il faut aussi accompagner et
aider d'antan dans ce projet à la
réalisation de ce projet pour qu'ils
puissent se remobiliser effective et
vous avez des réorientations ses accès
possible que justement un élève qui ai
commencé donc sa première année dans une
filière qui ne lui plaisait pas vraiment
qu'ils connaissaient mal qu'il a mal
appréhendé peu dans cette première année
changer de filière
alors effectivement souvent il arrive en
1ère année ils n'ont pas réellement
choisi c'est un choix par défaut et ils
n'ont pas non plus très bien lu le
contenu de la ddt de la discipline de la
filière dans laquelle il allait
s'inscrire et donc se retrouve un petit
peu perdu dans cette filière là et j'ai
perdu ce alors c'est possible de soirée
voilà alors la vraie orientation
effectivement dès le premier semestre
effectivement parce que souvent ces
étudiants-là se manifeste très tôt au
bout de quelques semaines souvent à la
toussaint ils sont déjà en perdition et
on peut organiser pour eux une
réorientation effectivement sur le
deuxième semestre alors que ces artistes
absolue m'attraper je salue les
financières voient là alors l'objectif
est quand même aussi justement de ne pas
les perdre qui ne perd pas une année
complète en allant travailler en
attendant la fin de l'année le mois de
juin est donc de les garder
tout au long de l'année et en organisant
aussi pour eux éventuellement des
remises à niveau dans les matières les
plus de base d'ailleurs le français
l'expression écrite et orale les
mathématiques le l'informatique et et
l'anglais d'accord il ya une personne
qui est interviewé dans le micro
trottoir qui disait il faut en fait
rendre obligatoire la présence des
étudiants que l'on pensé quoi alors la
présence des étudiants et je crois qu'il
faut garder la liberté pour les
étudiants de dalé l'université c'est un
monde de liberté alors après évidemment
le tonneau mis ça s'acquiert or voilà ça
et ceci sein de la compagnie ont
d'ailleurs que vous proposez n'est pas
obligatoire certains étudiants
décrocheurs peu c'est plutôt basé sur
l'opposition le volontariat
effectivement il est organisé
il y a des inscrits souvent ils ne
viennent pas en totalité où ils suivent
une partie de ces remises à niveau mais
en tout cas il existe ils savent qu'ils
peuvent venir et on leur délivre à la
fin toutefois une attestation une
certification si les a pas de sanction
si jamais via absolument pas ils se sont
trompés ils veulent pas sa voix il
perçoit un autre chemin et on ne peut
pas les prendre par la main il est
obligé effectivement à suivre ce
dispositif parce qu'il ya aussi une
différence entre le nombre de
d'étudiants en décrochage et ceux qui
sont suivies dans le cadre du dispositif
alors c'est du simple au triple
effectivement puisque nous en suivons à
peu près 4000 étudiants en première
année à première année un petit peu
moins mais hors des ut en voilà je joue
je provoque des réussites et c'est serré
absolument c'est un paraguay elle plus
structurée mais en première année de
licence
effectivement ils sont un peu moins de
4000 et l'année dernière nous en avons
suivi 305 très exactement donc mais
vraiment suivi avec un accompagnement
individualisé
mais les décrocheurs enfin c'est presque
10% identifiés ils étaient 1000 à peu
près mais sur 1000 décrocheurs presque 4
voilà avec les difficultés pas forcément
des décrocheurs mais avec des
difficultés relatives c'est quand même
beaucoup mais j'en ai aussi un autre
pourcentage cia que 27 % des étudiants
qui obtiennent leur licence en trois ans
absolument là donc c'est effectivement
pas beaucoup il ya des universités qui
ont fait le choix de mettre en place ce
dispositif d'accompagnement pour
certaines filières es qu a choisi son
côté de mettre en place ce système pour
toutes les filières oui il ya des
filières qui sont plus compliquées que
d'autres on pense par exemple un
médecine souvent localisation de messine
arrive en 1ère année c'est le disent
c'est souvent un peu l'enfer parce que
parce que j'ai beaucoup de travail que
oui alors bien sûr ils choisissent cette
formation parce qu'il souhaite bien sûr
arriver
à décrocher ce fameux concours en
première année et c'est la grosse
désillusion en fin de première année et
voir même il leur tente et la deuxième à
nier ça ne va toujours pas donc là
vraiment ils sont très très démobilisés
et décourager donc là il faut vraiment
les accompagner et les aider
quel à redire sur lequel vous portez les
attentions particules particulière
absolument à leur endroit
ils sont nombreux également tout le
monde ne réussit pas un endroit non plus
c'est une filière qu'il ne connaissait
pas au lycée qu'il découvre à
l'université et puis les allures a le
droit parce qu'il faut beaucoup
absolument le dispositif david existe
existe depuis trois ans il a été mis en
place grâce à un fonds dead
d'expérimentation notamment c'était un
fonds lancé par martin hirsch ces trois
ans après le bilan positif on continue
alors tout à fait il ay là il a duré
deux ans enfin de financement par le
fonds jeunes est évidemment vu son
utilité l'université a décidé de
pérenniser ce dispositif
et voilà nous fonctionnons et nous
continuons effectivement cette action
merci d'être venus en bâtiment que
l'université versailles saint quentin a
décroché la première place en matière de
réussite aux licences merci beaucoup
d'être venu en fait